justin trudeau espère convertir ses
poignées de mains en votes des
rencontres parfois courtes qui
s'enchaînent
d'autres plus longues comme celle avec
le premier ministre éthiopien
les deux hommes ont pris le temps de
discuter de nombreux enjeux comme l'aide
au développement et le commerce
international justin trudeau a aussi
participé à un événement sur l'équité
des genres où il annonce une subvention
de 10 millions de dollars à la
commission de l'union africaine pour
l'égalité des sexes de l'argent pour
montrer que les ambitions canadiennes
viennent avec des actions nous avons mis
sur pied la politique d' aide
internationale
féministe qui vise à éliminer la
pauvreté et à bâtir un monde plus
pacifique plus inclusif et plus prospère
mais un des adversaires du canada dans
la course pour obtenir un siège au
conseil de sécurité de l'onu n'est pas
bien loin
la première ministre norvégienne compte
elle aussi convaincre les pays africains
de voter pour son pays et elle croit
avoir une longueur d'avancé
le premier ministre lui garde son plan
de match afin de remporter un siège face
à la norvège et l'irlande
il fait la promotion de certains thèmes
qui lui sont chers dont la lutte contre
les changements climatiques
que ce soit dans le cadre du travail
qu'ont accompli ensemble pour l'économie
bleu ou de notre collaboration au
chapitre des technologies propres et les
nouvelles infrastructures
le canada est votre partenaire pour
l'avenir tout n'est pas encore joué
il reste quelques mois avant le vote de
juin les responsables de la campagne
canadienne pour un siège au conseil de
sécurité font preuve d'un optimisme
prudent
il suffit de vincent choisi radio canada
et ess abeba en ethiopie